[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Welcome to our first episode of WhatsApp
Prof for the new year
and we're back Walter
yes I don't know where the people will
be
grieved or pleased but we're back
and I must say that
um series that was in the slot of
WhatsApp Prof
was quite entertaining it was very nice
to see how the Lord has
um dealt with you and angry let me read
something from the Bible okay
I think it's in Exodus somewhere
must be around about Exodus 16 17 18. oh
yeah here we go
Martin this is the story when uh
Jethro
the father-in-law of Moses came to visit
him
and he came to visit Moses and we read
there from verse 7.
and Moses went out to meet his
father-in-law and did abeyance and
kissed him and they asked each other of
their welfare and they came into the
tent
and Moses told his father-in-law all
that the Lord had done and to pharaoh
and to the Egyptians for Israel's sake
and all that travail that had come upon
them by the way and how the Lord
delivered them
so they must have had a long powwow I
think they sat there and they talked and
they talked and Moses was bubbling over
and he was telling how the Lord LED
and the result was and Jethro rejoiced
for all the goodness which the Lord had
done to Israel
whom he had delivered out of the hand of
the Egyptians
and the story doesn't end there because
if you drop down to verse 11 it says now
I know that the Lord is greater than all
gods for in the thing wherein they dealt
proudly he was above them
was he there to witness all of these
things no he wasn't physically there no
but he believed Moses
okay
and then it went further and Jethro
Moses's father-in-law took a burnt
offering and sacrifices for God and
Aaron came and all the Elders of Israel
to eat bread with Moses's father-in-law
before God
so they all came together
and they all said and I'm sure they all
told the stories again in different ways
and from different angles and
perspectives so how important is it to
witness
extremely important it do it is
also a Thanksgiving
yes God acknowledging that God did it
exactly so you know Martin we are so
involved in all of our stories that we
tell about what's happening in the world
and
and just trying to get people to
understand that we're living in the last
days
but I thought
it was not a bad idea to give a witness
of how God has led in the past because
that's what we must not forget exactly
how it brings people together
and how he works with us in spite of our
imperfections
what I liked about Henry's story
is Henry was willing
was he perfect no
did he still do things that were wrong
in lifestyle and all of these things
yeah
now when the Lord let's say called men
to his Vineyard was I perfect
what do you mean
did you say definitely not well I know
where I was so I'm sure it was different
I think I was worse than you
and uh did he wait for me to be you know
spot on and perfect well he's gonna have
to wait a long time because now I'm
still struggling it's a progression
but it takes you where you are and he
works with your willingness
and he teaches you and there you go and
it's a witness we must also tell these
stories oh definitely
and I I'm sure in future episodes we'll
refer back to some of your
experiences because there's always
the other part that you also have to
bring forward correct to show people how
important is to keep your eyes on God
now what we showed there of course was
how God LED and how it came about
we didn't really accept for the the
Africa continent of Origins so what was
actually recorded
so that'll be the next thing because
that's the important those messages yeah
and uh if you if you know how God put it
together and how everything had to fit
into those time slots
because there was only that short window
every time because you have to be back
at your work
and how it happens I mean it's
unbelievable when you look back it's
impossible and then all the dramas that
come with it and all the catastrophes
that come with it and all the I don't
know it's it's just a nightmare
but looking back you can see the thread
now if Moses had told the story about
how the children grumbled when they got
to this place and there was no way
further how they got to the Red Sea and
there was nowhere further and I grumbled
and grumbled and he lifted at that
in the body of praise God yeah in the
golden Gulf yes if you if that was only
if it was if he only complained towards
Jethro
what what would have come there no
but you have to take the whole thread
the whole story and you have to the
outcome eventually is what is important
but we digress we want to talk about
let's open with a word of prayer then we
can get into this all right let's do
that
our heavenly father it's a privilege to
be back and it's a privilege to work for
you
and every single person has been called
to do this so we ask that you bless the
viewers Enlighten our minds theirs and
then help us through this discussion in
Jesus name amen amen
so we're going to talk about political
and spiritual games that's of course not
literal games those are the games that
people play with people's minds right
yes
yes and what can
2023 possibly bring
not a lot has happened if you take the
past two months that's gone
but there's enough to still show you
that there's a lot of pulling movement
behind the scenes going on and this this
whole what we've been talking about this
whole story of the pendulum
swinging yes he's really seeming to be
coming to the fall yes that's exactly
what we want to talk about the political
and spiritual mind games that the devil
plays and what can we expect about it
and
it's really a battle King of the North
King of the South we always come back to
that
but that's what it is about
just as we've mentioned I'm sure
previously that battle is not only on a
universal scale but it also goes into
organizations yes for instance like
maybe the Catholic Church
seems that there is also that battle
there but oh it has to be across the
board because it has to look so
realistic right
all right so here is an article in mail
online from the 13th of December
Pope warns he has seen Omens of even
greater destruction and desolation for
mankind
button you don't have to see Omens you
just have to read Matthew 24.
I think he must get away from his
catechism and start reading Matthew 24.
so I had a mass at the Vatican the pope
now 85 years old said on Sunday that he
has a dire vision for the world with
Omens of even greater destruction than
desolation
well that's not rocket science it
doesn't make him a prophet right no
the mass was commemorating the feast of
Our Lady of Guadalupe
which fell on Monday
it commemorates the appearance of the
Virgin Mary to a young man Saint John
Diego
in 1531 in Mexico City the day is a
national holiday in Mexico now
just you how deceived the world is right
because if you go to Jerusalem
there you will find Orthodox as well as
Catholic places of burial for Mary
it gets buried in many places did you
know that no but then she's not there
because she she had a Ascension right so
she didn't even go into that grave I
don't know what those graves will form
but I guess it's to meet the demands of
everybody and curiosity and what have
you
but the the Bible tells us where she is
she's sleeping in the Great
so uh whole nations
are honoring
something
that the Bible says is absolutely the
opposite of what they are doing that's
true but it just shows you how deceived
the majority is yes humanity is deceived
I think we must do something about that
and the great deceptions
uh I want to do a little talk at some
stage about the things that Paul talks
about when he says I do not want you to
be ignorant
and he uses that phrase and we'll have
to look at that I'm looking forward to
that in his homily the pontiff said it
is a better time filled with the
rumbling of War growing Injustice famine
poverty and suffering
but at this Bleak and disconcerting time
there are Omens of even greater
destruction and desolation I think he
might have read Matthew 24 after all
what do you think well
let's put it this way
this is for once he's correct all right
now does the devil know all of these
things for sure he's a great Bible
student isn't he he's a great scholar
and our Lady Lady of Guadalupe and Our
Lady of Fatima and Our Lady of majigori
and Our Lady of wherever
has predicted all of these great
calamities that would come right
and all of them are basically a copy of
what the Bible says exactly because it's
just a copycat but there's a difference
the reasons
the Bible gives us a certain reason and
the reasons that the devil is giving us
yes is actually he's giving Humanity the
problem that's the problem and and uh
talks about problems within the Catholic
church and you know
so if you see bad things within the
Catholic Church like you know all of
these sex scandals and pedophilia and
all of these horrible things that are
happening oh that's just like State
capture
it'll pass
but we're first going through this Great
Tribulation and then the greater things
will come I mean that's always the kind
of promise that we have but the Bible
says no it goes all the way to
destruction that's it it's going worse
yes
now Martin what's interesting
is for a long time now there were many
people
that were saying that Pope Francis is
basically a pseudo Pope the real Pope
was Benedict
and many believe that Benedict would
come to the fore and take over and
correct all the wrongs again
and then there were many that believed
that we are dealing with the literal
popes when it comes to the Fulfillment
of the pubs or the story of Revelation
chapter 17.
now I've always thought you know that is
very futuristic reasoning
because we are dealing with a spiritual
angle a spiritual fulfillment of the
greater realities of the literal types
so we're going to move in a particular
direction and have a particular
progression
and I was wondering what would the
people say if it doesn't work out that
way yeah
what if Benedict died before
France's which is actually what happened
now so there goes a lot of speculation
should that rattle us I don't think so
at all because the prophetic line is
still
on track 100
and there are people that are convinced
that the present Pope is the last one
and I certainly hope so he's 85 years
old I certainly hope he is the last one
but my cage won't be rattled if he's not
no I I agree with you there because
don't hang all your faith on
um something that's not clearly cut and
we will try to give a literal
interpretation to a text that is an
anti-typical application of a greater
reality all right let's just uh leave it
at that
but what is interesting many within the
Roman Catholic Church
see the present probe as liberal yes and
even as an antipope yeah even evil yes
and many had their hopes on Benedict
that it would you know go back to
wherever it should be but the fact of
the matter is there is this dichotomy
within the church and it's left against
right okay can we say that it's a game
of King of the North King of the South
within the Catholic Church which is not
possible because the Catholic church is
the King of the North so then it can be
uh it's a game it's a game that's the
thing it's not
but it's probably
not real no it's staged well aren't they
all actors these people and aren't they
portraying something to the outside
world and it seems as if there is this
conflict between right and wrong and
good and evil I mean that's also when I
was looking at all of this I actually
told you I went and looked at the two
popes the movie that was made yes that's
a long time ago yes yes 2019 and they
actually
portrayed again inside there they've got
this the whole dichotomy the whole time
this little battle going on between the
conservative and the liberal view of the
environment now we've been saying the
pendulum is going to swing
the pendulum is now really on the
liberal side right everywhere
and
spiritual so if they're pendulum swings
then once the papacy also swing
has to it has to right so whether it's
going to happen in in the portrayal of
one individual like Pope Francis
or whether there will come a another
Rottweiler
a conservative Pope it's immaterial how
it happens but it must happen must go to
the other side so let's see what the
what the situation was when this Pope
pop Pope Benedict died
a couple hours
it was a great and reminded me going
back to geology class we spoke about
Aquinas and about human theologica and
already I found them to be uh
relaxing very rational and uh you know
more conservative new within the
Catholic room than I have in case we
have both the threatened person from
your philosophy
well I I admired him I thought it was a
Founder you're not attending his funeral
tomorrow though why well why do you
agree well you tell me you know why I
can't even tell me sir the reason I'm
not attending to do anymore is because
it takes an Entourage with a thousand
people that show up not literally but if
we would just we would move everything
in the wrong direction I inquired about
and uh people are sending mostly their
Apostolic delegates where the folks in
young that's what we're going to do we
were just getting away
but I made my views known anyway
thank you sir
as the president said in his statement
as I'm sure you saw he joins Catholics
and so many others around the world in
mourning the passing of Pope Emeritus
Benedict XVI he will always remember the
Pope's generosity and me and meaningful
conversation they had when he visited
the Vatican in 2011 so to answer your
question the U.S ambassador to the holy
see Joe Donnelly will represent the
United States at the funeral of the Pope
in line with the wishes of the late Pope
and the Vatican this is what this is
what their requests were this is what
their wishes were and so that's what
you'll see
so that's exactly why we have commentary
all around Rome now that Pope Benedict
himself requested Biden not to come to
the funeral now wouldn't that be
interesting
so what was interesting about that one
Martin
is that Biden says he was more in tune
or is more in tune
with Pope francis's philosophy than he
was in tune with Benedict
and when he had discussions with him
they were talking about theological
things and he was in a theology class
and Thomas a kindness and all kinds of
boring things like that why don't they
talk about the Bible instead of all
these nonsense people that you know tell
you that it's fine to steal from other
people and break God's Commandments and
then they make them sense yeah that's
exactly what because it's a political
and a spiritual game yes and he wasn't
there because apparently it was the wish
of the previous Pope that he shouldn't
be there
but of course they're done playing that
now
if Biden is more in tune with Pope
Francis do you think that there are
other Catholics that were more in tune
with the other side with Benedict yes oh
definitely there were many now it's
interesting when you read the the
liberal newspapers or the left
newspapers they were actually quite
vociferous
saying more or less good riddance to
this Pope thank God he's gone
and the other side of course will say
the opposite so very interesting
so the Vatican plot to force Pope
Francis to resign conservatives wage
secret plan to put the liberal pontiff
under so much stress he will step down
Italian Cardinal reveals
then of course there's that interesting
book that now came out about the life of
the previous Pope and the conflicts that
there existed and you know all those
battle so-called in the church and that
was interesting when I was actually
re-watching this they already portrayed
or gave you this information
why would they make a movie Yes uh isn't
that's one of the main the Jesuits main
ways of giving it to the public yes and
certain is definitely not divided
against himself and the King of the
North whether he plays a liberal role or
whether he plays a a conservative role
Remains the King of the North exactly so
the speculation grows as the pope met
with Archbishop George genswein
on Monday the longtime Secretary of Pope
Benedict the 16th and a key figure in
his recent funeral
genswein has released an extraordinary
memra in which it costs Francis in a
deeply unfavorable life
so the conflict between right and left
right the Italian newspaper La stumper
reported that a cardinal had told them
the conservative faction is ready to
move against the Communist Pope
the Cardinal was quoted as saying the
secret plan will be formulated on
various axes and phases
but it will have one objective to place
the pontificate under such stress that
Francis will have to resign
well
we titled It games right exactly these
are games that they are playing
and they're moving in accordance with
the pendulum
and there's this movement to unseat him
and to put a conservative Pope in his
place so whether it will happen or not
we don't know
but
it is
in the news and when we
remember the one what we did about uh
Twitter and all of that it seems that
there's a move
to put this pendulum to the right to the
more conservative correct even in the
secular world yes
and so he continues that the Cardinal
added that the campaign would hinge upon
the progressive weakening of the Holy
Father as well as his doctrinal choices
which will create a great deal of
discontent which can be used against him
his appointment signaled a different
change in the Catholic church with his
criticism of capitalism and open
attitudes towards homosexuality abortion
communion for remarried divorcees and
celibacy for priests so la Stamper
reports said some opponents will be open
in their criticism of the Pope While
others will operate in the shadows
so all we are saying is there's a
movement and it is a movement to the
right
and it's actually accommodating the move
to the right in all the other spheres
yes because they set the tone right
all right let's listen to what some of
these Catholic conservatives had to say
on the issue because Martin
if we don't study the Beast
if our eyes are not on the Beast we will
not be able to pick up the plot that's
so important because I can already hear
just while you were saying this a lot of
people might be asking why are you
constantly talking about what's going on
in the papers what doesn't the Bible
says that they worship the Beast and
that's the problem we have to study it
we have to know what's happening yes
and besides that Martin
within our own ranks
there have been Publications in some of
our extremely liberal magazines
that we shouldn't give out the great
controversy
because we cannot afford to use the
paper because that requires trees and
that is against climate change I've
never heard a more ridiculous argument
than that in my life as to why you
shouldn't hand out the great controversy
because it contravenes a direct command
from God himself yes
we can do a whole episode on on this
because we don't want to give
foolishness too much bread no but we can
we can put uh the right things in the
right place yes so we'll we'll get to
those now many years ago there was an
altercation between myself and the
individuals that write these silly
things
and uh it is still floating around in
the web out there but let's leave it at
that let's hear what these Conservative
Catholics have to say on the issue
Pope Francis
made a dire warning to the the curia the
Cardinals and everybody else in the
Vatican warning them to be ever Vigilant
of demons lurking in the Vatican
now this was part of his Christmas
address which apparently he has turned
into uh uh an annual airing of
grievances someplace in his Christmas
address he will put some things where
he's you know kind of upset about inside
the Vatican he'll bury that in the
Christmas address so he says this
elegant demon is now lurking among the
Vatican staff
okay so is that just something that he's
like hey you know everybody's human and
we should just be careful ever Vigilant
could be could be
find it really interesting that he's
using those words
because I want to add something on top
of that
uh Pope Benedict who just died his
longtime personal secretary has written
a tell-all book that his publisher
promised would tell the truth about dark
Maneuvers Mysteries and Scandals that
sullied the reputation
of Pope Benedict
when Pope Benedict Was a cardinal
um he had a lot of friends and they were
other Cardinals and when they released
the final secret the Third Secret of
Fatima which if you're not Catholic it's
it's just a message from Heaven given to
these
um these kids you know right before
World War One and it said there's a huge
Russia is the problem it's going to
spread its error throughout the world
unless her heart is changed
um and they she there's going to be a a
World War coming soon and then there
will be a second world war and then a
final battle
um and you know it happened years before
World War one and World War II obviously
and then there was the third one the
Third Secret if you will about what sets
up the final battle
they released this and it was kind of
like uh okay that's old news ratzinger
who is Pope Benedict
said and this has just been uh published
that
um Pope Benedict said the Third Secret
has not been revealed in its entirety
because the pope and all those involved
uh would not allow it to be released or
if he was the pope I can't remember
which it was but but the but the power
did not want to release it because it
talks about
a bad counsel and a bad mass and evil at
the top and highest levels of the church
and that's the warning that was given to
them uh in you know like 1910 and it it
leads to the end of days
so I found it interesting that for
anybody who believes in any of these
kinds of of things
and if you believe in evil I find it
interesting that the current pope is
talking about evil
the last Pope is talking about evil
but I think they're kind of pointing at
each other a little bit you know I don't
think they're on the same side I think
they're both using evil but I
think they're not talking about the same
evil and aren't fighting the same evil
and then to have
this Fatima secret come out now
according to sources it is from uh the
Pope that just died I find it
fascinating
all right Martin so there you have a
little bit of background right
that's interesting in the previous one
there was a little short section where
they said that Pope Francis was
basically a communist yeah yeah all
right but they're denying that
now all the previous popes were at one
stage fighting communism like
John Paul II for example
and of course America was fighting
socialism and communism
and you have this Left Right issue in
the United States you know the Socialist
agenda which could lead to Communism and
then the more conservative agenda and
you have the same battle within the
Roman Catholic church right
now there's a book about all of these
intrigues behind the scenes now they
were set up with the CIA and the Vatican
called the book is called gladios
where they set up these these
organizations these military
organizations after the second world war
in all the various countries to actually
combat communism
and many of the things that took place
and the terrorist Acts were were
basically planned according to this book
by the Vatican and the CIA together
together with the mafia well if I may
just cut in here while he was speaking I
was thinking
Fatima they've got this
predictions these three yes and it's
Russia will be converted it will be
overcome and but if you are sitting
behind everything you will know
everything yes sir isn't China in the
same category it's also communist
and you know if you read Fox News Now
for example and let's just make it quite
plain we're not taking the side of the
right and we're not taking the side of
the lift because it's a game we're using
the information that they're using the
information now Fox News wants to say
that Biden as a communist agenda
and that he is in bed with the Communist
Chinese for example
and so you have this constant interplay
and if Fatima is correct
which of course we know is from a
demonic Source exactly and they the
people sitting behind if you really want
to look I'm sure you're going to get the
Beast
somewhere in the world to world wars oh
well I remember I gave a lecture on that
issue revolutions tyrants rewards yeah
that's that's an old lecture so they're
all behind us yeah so the evil will come
into the church
and it will appear to topple and fall
it's interesting language that we have
there it's a it's again a double play
but is it also happening to the True
Churches yes that's exactly what's so
interesting so this evil comes into the
church and this evil in the end
will have to be dealt with by
chastisements
so Mary's so-called in very thick
inverted commas
brings this message that there will be
chastisements in the entire world
great suffering
great turmoil isn't the pope predicting
that the first one what we saw is he
said even more destruction correct
but you know they're taking their cue
from from the Bible of course and then
this destruction comes in and then
the true church WIll emerge
and it will set the record straight so
that's the argument within the Catholic
Church
but of course the kings of the worlds
are also alive yeah and the world
economic forum is aligned and what role
is that playing left or right
that's the left they're playing the left
now I just received a uh document a PDF
document with all the world economic
Forum members
every single major corporation and bank
is aligned with the world economic forum
and most of the politicians and the
banks and the Bank of America and all
these jesuit-owned and Knights of Malta
organizations every CEO they're probably
largely Knights of Malta and then you
have of course the darling of the world
the Royal Family
which is also aligned with the world
economic Forum the playing the leftist
role
and here's an article in the express
about King Charles to honor the promise
and recognize all faiths at his
coronation
and you have again this dichotomy
you have this war between left and right
and there are people that are saying if
the United Kingdom
doesn't return to its Christian Catholic
roots
then it will fail
and then you have this other lot that is
aligned with the world economic Forum
Etc
so he's going to recognize all faiths
whether he does it or not is irrelevant
but he did say in the past that he wants
to be the defender of faith and not
defender of the faith
so King Charles reportedly plans to
recognize all faiths as he is crowned
next year with his coronation to honor
an old promise
Buckingham Palace confirmed last year he
would have his coronation on May in May
and recent reports suggest he will
commit to a previous pledge to serve as
defender of all faiths
now
according to the Bible the ten horns
give their power unto the Beast
in other words they must recognize the
so-called Christian
aspect again because the Beast is the
papacy pretending to be a Christian
organization
the traditional coronation oath sees the
Monarch promise to serve as defender of
the faith referring to the Church of
England
while that part of the oath will remain
unchanged the distance from AIDS will
reportedly allow him to recognize a
previous commitment to the UK
multi-faith landscape
only 46.2 percent of the people
identified as Christian on the March 21
2021 census day
the number of britons identifying as no
religion increased from 25.1 that's 14.1
million to
37.2 million so this definitely been a
move to the left the secular that I mean
the left like you said the King of the
South actually yes
and the Pendulum according to the
scripture has to move the other way
again irrespective of all of this are we
hearing those noises yes we can see it
happening and it's actually is that if
we see those figures it means there's a
lot of work
because we have to inform people of the
true God yes if there's a 37 percent of
the population
don't believe in anything yes now it's
very interesting what's happening in in
that respect now this next video that we
want to show is a church of England
cleric in fact he was basically the
chaplain to the Royal House
and he went over to the Catholic faith
but he is aligning himself more with the
thinking of Benedict it appears at least
then with the thinking of Pope Francis
so he's sitting in the shadows waiting
for the re-emergence of the old Power of
the Catholic church
and let's hear what he has to say on the
issue
well one of the things I've been saying
and people don't like me much for saying
it is that the the only hope for England
is the Catholic church and not just the
ordinary but but the whole Catholic
church because it is the only
organization with the philosophical
muscle and integrity to confront the
heresy of Relativity that we have and
and you know if the Catholic Church
stirred itself if it became awake then
it found its courage if it moved from
being a sort of sectarian subculture as
it has been over the last 150 years when
the default the fault of that is lies
with the English state but nonetheless
or whatever fault it is it has to come
out from behind this sectarian
subculture and then and claim England
for its own as the church in England the
church that Spent A Thousand Years
building the society upon which our
civilization was constructed but it's
it's been it's it's been subject to
snobbishness and marginalization and uh
association with with non-english
culture but that that needs to change
now ten percent of the Catholic clergy
in England at the moment our
ex-anglicans has been a great influx
it's time for the Catholic Church to
understand the great responsibility that
God has given it to help save
Christendom and to act as as spiritual
as well as it turns out it will also be
political saviors to to people who
inhabit Christendom
what did he say
religious and political exactly you must
always catch those buzzwords
that church and state and the Catholic
church does not work without State as
well now this is a very high official
who was in The Royal house as the
representative of the church he moved
over to Catholicism he is lamenting that
Catholicism is caught up in this liberal
non uh
combative if you like
era and he's longing for the return to
the old and they must claim England as a
Christian Heritage
now when it says the Ten Kings will give
their power unto the best beast who are
those Ten Kings well it could be a
double application it could be the 10
regions of the world and embrace the
entire world that's one aspect
but the great drama according to the
spirit of Prophecy
plays itself out within the Christian
nations
so the Christian nations must take back
their Christian Heritage
which has to be Catholic because they
have to give their power unto the Beast
not unto the Protestants and Protestant
America will reach over the gulf and
take the hand of Rome so these countries
that have been inundated with a liberal
theology
have been watered down by secularism and
have been infiltrated or let's say
migrated
with a lot of other religious systems
like Islam for example will have to
claim their Christian Roots again that's
a great conservative swing the Bible
says it's going to happen and religious
laws are going to be enacted again
now we have many laws on the books
because of various events that happened
over the last two years what it started
2001 with
the Twin Towers correct and those laws
made it possible to keep a nightclub in
the casino and a bar open but a church
closed yeah
now if the pendulum swings I think the
nightclub and the casino and the bar
will be closed and the church will be
open by law by law
and then we will have a Sunday law which
is on the cards Martin you see and once
again look how clever this is because
Christians of all denominations will
Embrace this yes because did they rise
up when the Bars were open and the
churches were closed so deceitful very
clever
so let's read what it says in the great
controversy
the ramish church now presents a fair
front to the world covering with
apologies her record of horrible
cruelties this is a very well known
quote Yeah but it it deserves to be read
again you know what
we like you've mentioned before this
book The Great controversy
is by order of God to be spread across
the world irrespective what the Liberals
say that it is a waste of paper and a
pollution to the environment
so
if that is the case
it cannot grow old no
she has clothed herself in Christ like
garments but she's unchanged every
principle of potpourri that existed in
past ages exists today
she has not changed one single Doctrine
the doctrines devised in the darkest
ages are still held let none deceive
themselves The Potpourri that
Protestants are now so ready to honor is
the same that ruled the world in the
days of the Reformation when men of God
stood up at the Peril of their lives to
expose their iniquity
she possesses the same pride and
arrogant assumption that lauded it over
Kings and princes
and claimed the prerogatives of God
her spirit is no less cruel and despotic
now than when she crushed out human
Liberty and slew the Saints of the most
high
it's interesting that these liberal
articles always want to tell us that
Rome has changed yeah they have no idea
she's become worse exactly much more
cunning
potpourri is just what prophecy declared
that she should be the apostasy of the
latter times
it is part of a policy to assume the
character which will best accomplish her
purpose
but beneath the variable appearance of
the chameleon she conceals the
invariable Venom of the serpent that's
so well put because it is so true so
you've got this game the conservative
and the liberal insight there but it
will put on a character that will best
accomplish her purpose so she can play
both parts both parts yes we are not
bound to keep faith and Promises to
Heretics she declares
shall this power
whose record for a thousand years is
written in the blood of the Saints be
now acknowledged as part of the Church
of Christ
it is not without reason that the claim
has been put forth in Protestant
countries that Catholicism differs less
widely from protestantism than in former
times
there has been a change but the change
is not in the papacy
Catholicism indeed resembles much of the
protestantism that now exists because
protestantism
has so greatly degenerated since the
days of the reformers so Martin
the reformers had such a Clear Vision of
what Catholicism was about if you read
gratan Guinea's romanism and the
Reformation if you read up in years
history of the Reformation
it is so clear
it is so brilliant when you read our
Pioneers yes
Oh Martin let's let our Pioneers speak
again I cannot stand to hear some of the
modern stuff that comes out of some of
our Quarters at the Pioneers speak again
they had such a clear voice this also
speaks will 10 percent of the Church of
England which was Protestant walk over
to Catholicism if they were actually
still holding on to the truths that the
Protestants no they definitely would not
and it's interesting how even the
sporting world and even calamities
within the sporting world can help the
pendulum to swing
that's an interesting video where we're
throwing that in there because it shows
that there is this tendency now to
invoke God and bring him into the
picture yeah something that never before
you would see on National Television or
anything and it gets praised not shot
down no and it's in in an era where
liberalism is actually acting High all
right this has to do with Damar Hamlin
who of course had this terrible tragedy
that's another discussion point and a
can of worms that we won't get into
but what happened on air is interesting
let's have a look
this is a little bit different I heard
I've heard it all day like thoughts and
prayers and you just heard sheriff and
Jonathan Allen said like all we can do
is pray for him and I've heard the
Buffalo Bills organization say that we
believe in prayer and maybe this is not
the right thing to do but I want it's
just on my heart that I want to pray it
is Lamar Hamlin right right now I'm
going to do it out loud I'm gonna close
my eyes I'm gonna bow my head and I'm
just going to pray for him
um
God we come to you in these moments that
we don't understand that are hard
because we believe that your God and
coming to you and praying to you has
impact we're sad we're angry
um and we want answers but some things
are unanswerable
we just want to pray
truly come to you
and pray for strength for Demar for
healing for Demar for comfort for Demar
to be with his family to give them peace
if we didn't believe that prayer didn't
work we wouldn't ask this of you God
I believe in prayer we believe in prayer
we lift up Demar Hamlin's name in your
name
amen amen amen
now Martin I don't doubt the sincerity
of these people at all it's not about
that no it's very important that we make
that clear yes it's about the public
move in a direction where God is
officially on the regular channels being
invoked in the acceptance of it yes it's
a sign of the pendulum swinging in the
other direction
so what was the response this is an
article from the 5th of January Faith
leaders cheer ESPN analysts moving
prayer on air
for Damar Hamlin he wasn't afraid
Martin this is a big swing isn't it
because you weren't allowed to mention
God without an uproar I mean you've had
that problem that that um coach
that did that prayer and it was all over
the news and he was in trouble he wasn't
allowed to pray now they're praying so
ESPN analyst Dan olowsky stunned
audiences when he said a prayer for
hospitalized Buffalo Bills
safety dhamma Hamlin during Tuesday's
edition of NFL Live
on Monday 10 million people unexpectedly
found themselves in a prayer meeting
the focus was on one football player
whose life was in Peril for a moment we
saw a life as God does
of incredible value and worth giving up
everything for us that's what the cross
is about pray he tweeted
button are they moving back to a
Christian country
would that enable them to give their
power unto the Beast yes would that
bring about Christian
legislation would that bring about a
desecration of the fourth Commandment
yes
did we hear similar sentiments in
England
that 100 all right let me ask the
question are we hearing it not only in
England but all over Europe in Germany
in Sweden in many many countries
of the people rioting in the streets and
they're tired of all the migrants and
the different religious sentiments they
want to go back to the old principles
wasn't this what we've you've been
always saying
with a Odo of cow this make it so
unbearable that all right let's go back
go back but then the Catholic Church
must move to the right as well
so what are we predicting here for 2023
and ahead well I think we're going to
see a movement of that inside the
Catholic church and within the world oh
for sure that's already happening and
the Christian culture cultures in
particular
if I may we just what about the the
speaker of the house now
before you know how long they took it
was what 15 times that they had to vote
or something I can't remember but one of
the congresswoman boobert
that was against and they had wanted
McCarthy the whole time to acknowledge
first what they require him to be doing
is the same one that said she's tired of
this church and state separation junk
uh-huh
interesting so there is more power going
to the church more power to the union of
church and state
so they claimed we value and join those
who believe prayer is vital to our
relationship to God through Jesus and a
powerful tool to unite the nation
towards a common goal and look what
massive roll sport can play now huh but
the millions of Americans who are
gathering together to pray for Damar
Hamlin is tangible proof of the unifying
power of sports
and believe that faith is fundamental to
our journey together as a people he
wrote in a comment on Fox News digital
I think we are moving in this direction
now so you have this tremendous battle
between the left and the right and this
tremendous battle about having
faith
and the secular
world view that is now so prevalent the
King of the North King of the South
issue so it might be interesting to
bring in this lady that was arrested for
praying within ahead
just to show how ridiculous the left
ideology can somewhat sometimes be not
saying that the right is going to be
better because it's going to do even
worse not at all the thing is
this can be an agitation yes that even
secular or even liberal people would say
oh this is getting ridiculous it's
getting too far so let's swing the
pendulum in the other direction all
right let's have a look what happened to
this just to set the stage
what are you here for today uh
physically I'm just standing here
what I hear of all places I know you've
been
in my head
um so I'll ask you once more will you
voluntarily come with us now to the
police station for me to ask you some
questions about today and other days
where there are allegations that you've
broken
if I've got a choice then
well then you're under arrest the class
suspicion of failing to comply with
public spaces protection order
um
September this year the local Council in
Birmingham brought in this censorship
Zone this PSP
um formerly these were used for dog
fouling and drunken behavior and things
like that but they're now popping up
around the country
um surrounding abortion centers and they
ban Behavior like protesting
um but it also names prayer and
counseling as forms of protesting
and so four times I went and stood near
the closed Abortion Center and silently
prayed there and as you can see the
police came and asked me if I was
protesting
which I wasn't they asked me if I was
praying and I said I might be silently
praying
um I was arrested I was searched I was
locked in the cell I was then
interviewed or interrogated however
you'd like to see it
um during which I was quizzed about what
I was praying about
um I was then released on bail and then
subsequently charged on four counts of
protesting and engaging in an act
intimidating of service users
um so I now stand on on trial on
February the second supported by ADF Uka
um really for freedom of thought
um and the concern is here in England
that
um National buffer zones are now being
discussed so there's a possibility of
every Abortion Center in this country
having a similar Zone around it
um and obviously the implications of
that are really concerning
well Martin
that would irritate anyone if you are
arrested for what you are thinking
dystopian you cannot think that you it's
orwellian orwellian oh what
so what are you thinking I'm you're
going to jail now for what you're
thinking imagine if if they had to
analyze what I think sometimes I think
we would be in big trouble right
okay then you have this balenciago
disaster
Balenciaga finally cops to mistakes in
disturbing BDSM ad campaigns condemns
child abuse amid scandal
so here was this uh organization that
was using miners in all kinds of others
fashion house they were actually putting
out adverts with kits in it but the
subliminal messages were just
unbelievable
and there are all of these things they
weren't content to grin and bear it amid
Fierce backlash Balenciaga has doubled
down on its stance for the controversial
ad campaign that depicted kids alongside
bondage style attire and a child
pornography Court ruling you know I
don't even want to read it no but just
think of this
I just put the some of the pictures in
but just think of this
it's on purpose
because how many secular and even
non-religious people also were Disturbed
with it they were Disturbed this has to
change and if they say this has to
change and the only option is to go back
to those Christian values then even many
as secularists will say all right better
than this definitely
all right so these are some of the
pictures of things that were going on
there let's not go too deep into it but
it's interesting the documentation that
was on the table on these pictures so
let's just see what little light Studios
did about it we will take a little clip
from what they had to say
so here is a is another reason why
people were calling for them to just be
canceled and taken off of the internet
people stop supporting them don't be
buying their stuff was because they put
a um a campaign picture out and
underneath this bag is a bunch of legal
documents and so people as they were
starting to get upset about what these
guys were putting out they started going
back and zooming in and looking at this
and what was on this legal document was
a legal document that contained excerpts
of a U.S Supreme Court opinion in the
States versus Williams which upheld a
federal child pornography law and why
would you even be putting children in
very provocative ways on your on your
products ads and then all of a sudden
having things like this underneath your
bag that literally the camera is never
going to you're not going to see that
unless you literally Zoom right in so
this is really disturbing that this
stuff is is coming out like that
so Martin let's just make a point again
we're not on the soapbox remember we
said we're not going to climb on a
soapbox we're looking at Trends that's
why we showed just not one thing we
bring it together yes so you have all of
these things that are pushing the left
agenda over the top
so that rational people will say this
has gone too far
and the only other alternative that
there is is the one that you've already
set in place
and that's going to lead to the
Fulfillment of Bible prophecy
so here's a quote from Christ's object
lessons the world is perishing for want
of the Gospel there is a famine for the
word of God
there are few who preach the word
unmixed with human tradition
though men have the Bible in their hands
they do not receive the blessing that
God has placed in it for them
the Lord calls upon his servants to
carry his message to the people
the word of Everest lasting life must be
given to those who are perishing in
their sins
so Martin you have the left and you have
the rights
and the right is mingled with the church
church and state together pushing for an
agenda to set matters right
the Catholic church plays a major role
in all of this and power will be given
to their View
that's how you give power unto the Beast
right
and that view will be implemented
that's what the Bible says and if you
then follow that view in its contrary to
the Bible then you are worshiping the
Beast
that's what happens right now in the
midst of this conflict neither of the
two sides
are in harmony with the scriptures
that's important exactly the one seems
to be the Christian one that's very
deceptive
and I've always said you know
deception is worse than direct blatant
error
because deception you don't really know
and I've always used the example if
someone says if they're married and they
say I love you I love you I love you and
then you find out they've been cheating
for five years or whatever you know what
does that mean that's deception that
hurts more than saying I hate you I hate
you I hate you and you find out they're
cheating right that's true so that's how
it works so in the midst of this
dichotomy
there must be a voice
and the voice that God has put into the
world is the Three Angels messages that
has to come from The Remnant that's it
and they have a qualification yes and
their qualification is that they have a
particular line of evidence
that sets the matter straight so that
you don't get so confused it's called
the spirit of Prophecy we have to talk
some more about that again in the next
one we will Okay so this message has to
go out now within the group that has to
give the message the final warning to
humanity will there be a dichotomy there
as well exactly the same so do we all
run and give up or do we do our job now
is the time to buckle up and get on with
it get on with it and do the work
Genesis 6 5 and God saw that the
wickedness of man was great in the earth
is it great now oh yes
and that every imagination of the
thoughts of his heart was only evil is
it so now just look at it
but as the days of Noah were so shall
also the coming of the son of man be for
in the days that were before the flood
they were eating and drinking and
marrying and giving into marriage until
the day that Noah entered into the ark
and knew not
until the flood came and took them all
away so shall it also be at the coming
of the son of man not modern
they're just carrying on with their
normal lives it's chaotic but they're
still doing what humans are doing
exactly but they don't know that the
door of probation is closing who knows
that the remnant The Remnant knows it
doesn't the remnant know what the sign
of the clothes of probation is yes well
shouldn't you be shutting it from the
rooftop no they rather put it away and
don't want to make a noise and say that
we can't afford the trees to print the
paper to give to the people exactly I
mean I've never heard anything more
ridiculous than that but we even have
such ridiculous things within our own
ranks right
and then Luke has the same thing to say
likewise also as it was in the days of
lot that brings in all of these
perversions
they did eat and they drank they bought
and they sold they planted and they
built it but the same day that lot went
out of Sodom it rained fire and
brimstone from heaven and destroyed them
all was there close of probation
even thus shall it be in the day when
the son of man is revealed is there a
group of people that know the criteria
for the close of probation yes time to
be silent right no they've got a duty
so that's our plan for 2023
if you ever thought that we were
shouting
we're going to try and Shout louder
would you agree amen let's pray
Heavenly Father
as we head for these final events
give us a voice like a trumpet
to tell the house of Israel her sins and
to warm the entire world
not to accept the spurious
for the true is my prayer in Jesus name
amen amen
[Music]
foreign